Klimaforschungs-Teams weltweit sind sich einig:
Die Rückkehr von El Niño steht wohl kurz
bevor.
Das Wetterphänomen hat immer wieder auf ein
Neues verheerende Auswirkungen - und das auf
der ganzen Welt: sintflutartige Regenfälle,
Orkane und Flutkatastrophen.
Nicht umsonst wird er auch als “Biest”,
Godzilla” oder “Monster” bezeichnet.
Wie wahrscheinlich seine Rückkehr wirklich
ist, wann wir mit El Niño rechnen müssen
und welche Auswirkungen er auch auf Europa
haben wird - das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction, herzlich willkommen!
2015 und 2016 waren die letzten beiden Jahre,
in denen das Wetterphänomen El Niño auf
der Erde gewütet hatte.
Es gab verheerende Waldbrände - beispielsweise
in Indonesien - , Überschwemmungen in Paraguay
und Ernteausfälle in Südafrika und Indien.
Und das sind nur einige wenige Beispiele der
zahlreichen Auswirkungen, die El Niño damals
zu verantworten hatte.
Doch auch in diesem Winter 2018/2019 müssen
wir uns wohl darauf gefasst machen, dass uns
die gewaltigen Stürme eine chaotische Wetterlage
mit krassen Niederschlägen, Flutkatastrophen
und Erdrutschen bescheren werden.
Zerstörung, Krankheiten und Tod folgen dem
meist - genauso wie enorme wirtschaftliche
Probleme.
In Australien, Südasien, Südafrika und Mittel-
sowie Südamerika kommt es dann zu fatalen
Dürren; in anderen Regionen der Erde wie
beispielsweise dem Östlichen Nordpazifik
bedrohen Wirbelstürme und Überflutungen
Land und Leute.
Die aktuellen Bedingungen lassen sowohl die
amerikanische Ozeanbehörde NOAA als auch
das japanische Wetterbüro ziemlich sicher
sein, dass El Niño kurz bevor steht: Die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür. dass dieses Wetterphänomen
im kommenden Winter auftritt, wird mit 80
Prozent angegeben.
Konkret schließen die Fachleute das aus den
Temperaturen im östlichen und zentralen Pazifik.
Denn wenn sich das Wasser dort aufheizt, ist
das ein klares Zeichen dafür, dass El Niño
droht.
Dort lag die Temperatur in der letzten Wochenbilanz
ein Grad über dem langjährigen Mittel.
Ab dem Wert von 0,5 Grad spricht man tatsächlich
von einem El Niño, wobei dieser mindestens
auf einer Monatsbasis überschritten werden
muss.
DAS genau ist noch nicht überall der Fall,
wobei dies nicht wirklich als Entwarnung zu
werten ist.
Denn in allen wichtigen Regionen liegt die
Temperatur über dem langjährigen Mittelwert.
Der Großteil der aktuellen Prognosen geht
derzeit davon aus, dass die Temperatur weiter
erhöht bleibt und auch die Atmosphärenluft
auf dieses warme Wasser reagieren wird.
Und dies macht einen El Niño sehr wahrscheinlich.
Doch wie genau entsteht dieses Wetterphänomen
eigentlich?
Im Normalfall sorgen die Passatwinde dafür,
dass das Wasser entlang des Äquators im Pazifik
von Osten nach Westen gedrückt wird.
Denn die Passatwinde zirkulieren zwischen
dem Tiefdruckgebiet vor der Ostküste Australiens
und dem Hochdruckgebiet vor der Westküste
Südamerikas.
Der jeweilige Druckausgleich bestimmt die
Windgeschwindigkeiten, die dabei entstehen.
Kalte und warme Meeresströmungen kreisen
übrigens parallel dazu, wobei die kalte Meeresströmung
aus dem Süden als “Humboldtstrom” bezeichnet
wird und für ein ausgeglichenes Klima im
Meer sorgt.
Bei einem El Niño bricht das Hoch zusammen
und zwar auf der Südhalbkugel zur Weihnachtszeit.
Deswegen bedeutet El Niño auch so viel wie
“Christkind” - so haben die peruanischen
Fischer dieses Wetterphänomen mal genannt.
Für die Fischer dort bedeutet das eine große
Katastrophe, denn viel Fische sterben oder
verlassen die Region.
El Nino ist ein Christkind, das Unglück bringt.
Wenn die Passatwinde also bei einem El Niño
zusammenbrechen, blasen sie extrem stark in
entgegengesetzte Richtungen.
So verändern sich auch die Meeresströmungen:
Warme Wassermassen bewegen sich von Ostasien
aus zurück in Richtung Südamerika.
Es sind wirklich gigantische Mengen an Wasser,
die da sich da durch den Pazifik bewegen und
ihre Wärme vor Südamerika an die Luft dort
abgeben.
Der Humboldtstrom wird abgeleitet und durch
die Erwärmung des Meeres verenden die Tiere
in ihm und das Plankton auch.
Doch nicht nur im Pazifikraum sorgt dieses
Wetterphänomen für Unruhe und Zerstörung,
denn auch die Passatwinde rund um den Globus
werden dadurch beeinträchtigt.
Somit gibt es auch Auswirkungen in Europa
- der eisige Winter 2009/2010 beispielsweise
ist nach Ansicht vieler Fachleute eine Folge
des El Niños.
Zu den Ursachen des Phänomens wird weltweit
noch geforscht, doch es gibt viele Spekulationen.
Einige Forschungsteams gehen davon aus, dass
die Sonneneruptionen eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Wir hatten darüber auch schon mal bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction berichtet - alle vier Jahre
nämlich verändert sich die Intensität dieser
Eruptionen.
Quasi im El Niño-Rhythmus: Das Phänomen
tritt nämlich in unregelmäßige Abständen
von durchschnittlich vier Jahren auf.
Deswegen wird spekuliert, dass die abgestrahlte
Energie der Sonne Einfluss darauf nimmt.
Viele Experten sehen aber auch die globale
Erderwärmung als verstärkenden Faktor.
Sie gehen davon aus, dass El Niño deswegen
zukünftig häufiger auftreten wird.
Dies zeigen einige Modelle, zum Beispiel Untersuchungen
des Kieler Klimaforschers Mojib Latif.
Demnach werden sich die El Niño-Ereignisse
unter der globalen Erwärmung intensivieren.
Falls sich das Phänomen weiter verstärken
würde, hätte dies nach Prognosen des Kieler
Forschungsteams auch für europäische Regionen
weitreichende Folgen.
Dazu Latif in einem Interview (mit dem Deutschlandfunk
im Jahr 2015): “Sowohl Nordeuropa als auch
Südeuropa würden dann sehr stark auch unter
den Einfluss des El Niños geraten und wir
hätten dann beispielsweise extreme Trockenheit
im Mittelmeer-Raum”.
Wir bleiben in diesem Winter dran und berichten
hier weiter über die Folgen des “Christkinds”.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
auch den englischen Kanal, denn auch da gibt
es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Ice Age in Europe
- Will the Gulf Stream come to a standstill?
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
kanal auch.
Stay tuned, see you soon!